[Music]
every fps game has those
superstars who just love to dunk on
people
whether it's in counter-strike apex
legends overwatch
or valorant these players will do
whatever it takes to add you to their
highlight reel
their jaw-dropping mind-blowing plays
take subreddits by storm turning even
the biggest
backseat kenny s's into love struck
groupies
and whether it's because of their raw
aim or their massive brain
these are the gamers who everyone looks
up to
rock stars who thousands of fans flock
to when they go live
every day
i mean i mean is this guy signed or what
but what if i told you that one of
twitch's most worshipped head poppers
wasn't a pro player dumpstering scrubs
in his spare time
that instead of chasing world
championships brandon
a sue nguyen has dedicated his life to
building an empire out of stylish
humiliations
kind of my end goal right now is like i
want to design my own brand
and eventually have my my own boutique
my own store and
end up being some old 80 year old asian
guy selling clothes or something like
it'd be it'd be a dream come true if i
get all that done asu
is nrg's certifiably cracked frag lord
who after
years of pursuing a competitive career
has opted to cement himself as one of
the most
exciting streamers on the planet one who
if
given the chance will happily make an
absolute
fool out of you
i'm [ __ ] gross
oh i didn't even do it like that but i
didn't like the atoms so
why did someone with such insane aim and
talent
lose interest in being a pro player and
how has asu
used his style of play to become one of
twitch's most beloved
fps streamers what's good y'all good
morning y'all
[Music]
okay so in addition to being one of the
nuttiest apex legends players
ever to touch the game who is asu
well before he began clapping kids in
various games online
asu lived a pretty quiet life he grew up
in the small
agricultural town of terre haute where
there wasn't a whole lot to do
to kill time asu played baseball in
school and
absolutely despised it but it was when
his stepfather introduced him to quake
that his competitive spark was truly
ignited
so i played quake against him and his
friend and obviously i was like really i
was probably like
seven or eight or something at the time
and he's just they're just like
destroying me and i'm not but
i can't kill them at all i'm just
getting absolutely trashed and so like i
kind of
like that kind of started like my uh
kind of like competitiveness because
like i always wanted to like
hang with them and like not be
completely useless i think that's like
the first real memory i had of like
playing games
now while asu enjoyed playing pc games
like quake with his step
dad and friends at the time he didn't
actually own his own computer
so instead he opted to play games like
call of duty
and halo on console initially drawing
inspiration from a halo youtuber named
celaya now celaya was known for styling
on his opponents with
unorthodox plays and it was that
highlight driven approach that inspired
asus content creation philosophy
get [ __ ] [ __ ] on there buddy ever
since then i tried to like feel like a
lot more flashy and creative with the
stuff that i was going for
and so whenever i'm going for uh
whenever i'm like going for clips i just
try to make something fresh you know
and something is unique i feel like
anybody can like go and like one tap
somebody but
it takes a little bit of player to like
get those like crazy plays you know
please bubble please
[Music]
eventually an esports center called
ebash opened up in terre haute where
players could go to play
with or against each other in various
local events
and that's where asu began spending his
weekends
stomping kids so i pretty much would
just be there all the time it's like
grinding games because i didn't really
have internet at my house
on like max box or anything so pretty
much just started
really young playing gears halo and cod
i played a few tourneys
i did okay but it wasn't anything crazy
i wasn't going like any mlg events or
anything
eventually i think i kind of hit a
barrier with all the the console games
and so that's when i started really
getting to pc gaming but when asu
finally got his first computer in 2013
he fell into the same trap that many
unfortunate souls have succumbed to
he became a filthy league scrub oh man
oh god oh man oh god
oh man oh god oh man
initially after hitting diamond in
season three asu was hopeful that he
might be able to make a name for himself
as a competitor
but after losing nearly every game in
his quest to hit
challenger the following season he
decided that
riot's moba just wasn't for him
and it was around that time that asu
discovered the fps that would kickstart
his gaming career
the goat that is cs go asu
or ace as he was known back then was
immediately hooked on cs go because of
its precise gun play
and so he poured hours upon hours into
it with the hope of eventually going pro
he even found a team to compete with at
an esca open qualifier
that's kind of where everything started
for me because we played the esa open
one season and we went to the second
season which is im but we ended up
winning intermediate which put a strain
to premier league
that's kind of where i started getting
my footing really and like my
i started getting my name out there a
lot and it was rise nation's performance
in esea's premier division
that caught the attention of e-united
who quickly
signed the exciting fragger to a pro
contract
after grinding for years to make a name
for himself
this was finally the big break that ace
had been looking for
or so he thought after
narrowly missing out on a qualification
for the 2018 face it london major
followed by a string of inconsistent
results
ace found himself sitting on the bench
because when whenever i got benched from
cs it's kind of like a wake-up call
because like
i spent all this time grinding and
grinding and i finally made it and i
thought like
oh this is like where everything's gonna
start and then i got benched and i had
nothing to fall back to so i was like
uh it really really just woke me up and
opened my eyes to how
quickly things can just you know be
pulled from under your feet now without
a job
asu had a difficult decision to make
he'd received offers from other teams
but he didn't want to settle for
anything less than pro league
so like the countless pro gamers before
him ace decided
to start streaming more but first he
wanted to change his in-game name
i found out that like ace is probably
the worst name i could have ever picked
getting into like the
the fps genre because if you kill a
whole team it's an ace it's pretty hard
to find your name like the algorithm
when all these clips about
people acing are there right so i kind
of ditched ace and i started going with
a2 it's just a lot easier to find
and his decision to go all in on
streaming and the rebrand that came with
it
would change his life forever in the
first few months
asus set a goal of hitting 400 subs
which
his talent and personality allowed him
to do pretty easily
but it didn't hurt when twitch's latest
craze hit in february of 2019
high five apex legends was the perfect
game for asu
because it rewarded players for their
raw aim
its frenetic pace was similar to the
arena multiplayer games he played when
he was younger
and so he used that to his advantage
riding the game's
wave of popularity into the streaming
zeitgeist
no dude
it wasn't long before asu's insane
highlights were turning up in
everyone's twitter feeds which
eventually prompted nrg esports to sign
him to their apex roster
he and his teammates dizzy and more
quickly became
fan favorites by winning multiple
twitchcon qualifiers
before winning the finals at twitchcon
san diego
where asu was named the events mvp
but fans weren't just marveling at his
incredible aim
they became obsessed with his movement
to the point where everyone wanted to
replicate it
and so asu's youtube channel became a
place where players could go
not just to watch his crispy one-taps
and humiliating outplays
but also to learn from the master
himself
so my job here is i'm going to show you
how to use the mechanics movement
and at the beginning i'm going to show
the basic inputs and how to do it but
later in the video i'm going to show
actual examples and i'm going to try and
walk you guys through
what's going through my mind and it was
the relationship between asu and his
viewers
that really catapulted him to the top of
twitch
it also helped him realize that he
enjoyed streaming apex legends
more than playing it professionally
which led to him walking away from his
competitive career in january of 2020
but despite the fact that he loved
creating content and
interacting with his audience the rng
factor of battle royales began tiring
him out
and losing games due to factors beyond
his control
took a toll on his motivation now asu's
viewership had
always been on the rise but in april of
2020 it was taken
to the next level by you guessed it
valorent the closed beta launch of
riot's long-awaited shooter
coupled with a twitch rivals event
catapulted asus channel
and allowed him to become one of the
faces of the game from day one
and the creative agent abilities valor
and offered players
allowed asu to take his
humiliation-based playstyle
to a whole new level
[Music]
one enemy remaining
nailed them
30 seconds left one enemy remaining
in the span of just one week issue
transformed himself into one of twitch's
biggest streamers hitting his peak
numbers for both subscribers
and viewers now with the sudden hype of
valorant
many people ourselves including were
hoping
that asu would go pro in this fresh
brand new game
but as it turns out he just didn't want
to distance himself from the cushy
lifestyle of streaming
and honestly how can you blame him
the life of an esports pro is stressful
demanding
and has a limited shelf life so for asu
choosing to switch to streaming was the
best move he ever made
so honestly i think if any player has
the chance to do it either like
me or shroud or tins have done i think
they should definitely do it um
because unless you have that competitive
drive to
be number one and just destroy all the
competition and
take your take that route um streaming
is a lot more it's a lot more relaxed
you can do what you want on your own
schedule and play what you want
and a lot less pressure and it's just uh
it's just really nice compared to
playing competitive
but no matter how big his streamer
numbers get asu remembers that his
empire was built on the bond that he
forged between
him and his audience and that's
something he keeps in mind
every time he goes live it's definitely
a lot harder
because like a lot of like a lot more
comments coming in and like
uh twitch chat is like going faster and
faster it's kind of hard to read
everything but i try
my hardest to still try and connect with
everybody i can't talk to everybody but
i can at least try you know
i hate watching a stream where like the
person just completely like dialed into
the game like for the whole time and no
one don't interact with chat so i try to
talk to everybody as much as i can
regardless of whether he's playing
professionally or just entertaining
people on stream
asu still has that hunger to clown on
anyone unfortunate enough to line up
with his crosshair
because no matter what game he chooses
to play
he will always be looking to create his
next
mind-blowing highlight i take life day
by day
and i don't really plan too much out so
the fact that i made it here i
just kind of take it as everything like
worked out as i should and i'm
you know i'm kind of blessed to be what
i'm doing right now
that's my last line of defense i'm
kidding i'm here to help you
i'm going stupid
start streaming more i actually love
that line that's a really good line i
wish i could you go on twitter and you
go to
every single [ __ ] pro gamer in the
history of esports who like when they
get banned straight or that you know
like
well first thing is i'm gonna use that
exact turn of phrase i'm gonna start
streaming more
that's like well you'll definitely see
me streaming more right like
that's a good i really wish i'd written
this sentence my hat's off denial this
is a good i like this a lot it's funny